thank you
[Music]
so you guys know about we were talking
about this earlier like sometimes
parents pressure their kids into careers
that they didn't want yeah Will Smith
has shared that he regrets uh pushing
his kids into acting really why did he
push his kids or did his kids get pulled
into acting so true I mean Jaden Smith
is weird and he's probably like man
acting did this [__] so I should have
told him to be an engineer [__] him up
so Jaden and Willow have admitted they
were unhappy with their father for
pushing them into this Spotlight at a
young age although the kids careers were
taking off the uh King Richard Starr
confessed that his family didn't share
the same sentiments as their father 2010
was like the greatest years an artist as
a parent Karate Kid came out in June
with my hair came out in October if you
remember Jaden Smith had Karate Kid
Willow Smith had with my hair uh Smith
shared on Kevin's heart and Kevin Hart's
Heart to Heart series
I'm building this dream of a family I've
had in my mind I'm gonna do it better
than my father did it and so maybe he
overcompensated a little bit right
with just those two projects probably
set them up for life for real dude
Willows she got a crazy uh song out that
out I can't I love dude I whip my hair
back and forth no not that one it's like
there's a crazy voice yeah sing it sing
it
yeah really that's uh wait a minute yeah
I don't hear the weight I don't hear any
of it sounds like an Indian song I hear
a I think no it sounds like that yeah
I swear to God the third time I was like
yep that's it I swear to God
every time I play it crazy in the gym
everyone's like who is this you can play
it from your phones but we'll get it
we'll get it down
yeah come on dude it's too sick I'm sure
you guys heard it too it's very good so
what was it so what was he supposed to
do is push him into what they're in the
biz you know well look I think this is
one of those affluent guilt things yeah
I think so too was he supposed to tell
them to be a scientist or some [__] you
guys ready yeah
[Music]
say something say something say
something
oh my God this is commentary blah blah
blah we're commenting it's fair use it's
gonna come on soon it's gonna come on
soon
you guys know this song yeah
I know
it actually is really cool it's a very
good song I love this song they're very
talented
I mean I came from
um a music family so it's like
wouldn't it be stupid for my parents to
never even let me touch the instruments
and like not even let me explore with
that but I think they didn't career eyes
you
um they were trying to they were trying
to but I just sucked at it they were
trying to make your Prof they're trying
to make you a professional at five years
old they were trying to get me toward
that route at five like at a really
young age and me and my brother and we
both resisted it I'll say this if you
were if Will Smith was your dad I don't
think he could make you go into acting
Joe just called what was going to do
with Joe whatever that is yeah that's
true because that's the scary part yeah
the scary part too with us and Tycho
where I'm like there's a difference
between passing down the skill or craft
versus career Rising them at that age or
like giving them a job what's the
difference for you
well the minute that your your earner
and you're trading your time for money
like you're turning into employee like
right away and I feel like you start
losing out on your childhood like crazy
you're not gonna explore the phase
anymore and you only have this phase of
your life to explore make mistakes and
do all that versus like now Jaden and
Willow are going to board meetings exec
meetings got to meet with Studios you
know like you have to meet with your
client like there's all these other
business really stiff things that it's
like you kind of just take the fun out
like maybe acting could have been really
fun and you just took all the fun away
there's so much pressure being that one
identity if you're not even sure that's
the identity yeah yeah yeah hot take too
I think that it's scapegoating I think I
think when based on the kind of weird
mantras that we've already seen Will and
Jada have and the way they raise their
kids and the [__] unrealistic Mansion
they grew up in they're not going to
turn out like normal people that's very
true it's like it's it's already a given
like they're not going to have normal
interactions with other kids they're
going to have a lot of [__]
complications I don't think it can be uh
I don't think it can be centered on
whether they chose acting or not and
just because they're willing Jada's kids
they're already put on a pedestal or
yeah like a star power that is not going
to be like normal they've raised them to
be anything but normal like whether they
were actors or [__] botanists they're
gonna be the weirdest [__] botanists
at the place they did make them pretty
weird so will says nobody in my family
was happy no one wanted to be in a
platoon like they're at War together
basically Willow was the first one to
begin the Mutiny and it was my first
realization that success and money don't
mean happiness up until that point I
really believe that you could succeed
your way to a house and family and you
could win your way to happiness
I think that's a pretty like yeah
vulnerable thing to say that's very
vulnerable do you feel like it's
conveniently vulnerable though
I think he's not the most liked person
right now and saying [__] like this
helps
she's not I think will is still likable
yeah it just feels like what's going on
in their marriage to where like
she's she just doesn't like you so much
like where did you [__] up but also it's
like will what's behind like after that
slap I was like you used to be likable
but you're also a little [__] man
that's a lot yeah that was a lot and
then that both that couple I'm just like
I don't know what's under what's going
on that's [__] weird I'm I grew up
such a big Will Smith fan so I want to
put all the blame on Jada and I'll take
him
exonerated yeah like she's the one
messing with him she's messing with his
brain and I think that's what the reason
is so I'll stick with that do you think
it's kind of ironic when someone goes
yeah I learned this lesson about life
but yet they've acted in so many
episodes that taught that lesson and the
shows they've been in that's such a
unique take yeah I've never heard that
thing because he should just re-watch
the Freshman yeah
oh [__] yeah learn from your own project
yeah like Tim Allen one day going I
should have improved my home
his house is just [__] [__] it was
definitely not a method actor yeah yeah
or or what if you just were to like
watch all the episodes and then just
take note of Uncle Phil because he seems
like the best dad ever or Julia white
going I think family does that I'm alone
family
it's like really okay because I learned
that from you doing it that's crazy
where the [__] did you learn it wow so
in 2012 Willow shaved her head bald in
the middle of her Whip My Hair toward
the send a message to her father whoa
she's over father halfway through the
tour she wanted it out he insisted she
continued with the plan shows prompting
the then 11 year old to take drastic
measures see that's tough when you're
career rising and you're 11 yeah and
you're on tour yeah that's a big
responsibility the formula already yeah
and you got like thousands of people
buying tickets she's like oh I'll do
this anymore I don't want to perform it
I already did like 37 cities yeah you
got 12 more to do yeah almost there
almost there sweetheart also you know
what I didn't realize she was um Will
Smith's kid in I Am Legend
oh really yeah Willow was yeah she
played his daughter and then his son his
kid in Pursuit yeah yeah
and he's yelling at him the whole time
yeah that's tough man they were babies
back then yeah they were so cute man
another all weird and teenagers they are
weird with Jaden that was their that was
their box office bomb that was what
killed Jaden Smith's career business
really wait what killed his career after
after Earth
movie with him and Jaden and it was
father son but like it bombed so they
blamed Jaden basically is that the one
where he's like will has like a CG
version himself that's younger uh no
that's a different one oh did that bomb
too that's Gemini man oh [__] bomb big
time the hope for that movie was
hilarious though it was like Will Smith
like against himself in the mirror and
like wouldn't everyone like to see this
movie and I was like I don't give up it
was like him versus his Fresh Prince
self and you know to Will Smith he's
like that's insane okay so that's tight
yeah yeah but everyone's like I don't
need to see this movie a lot of the
movies that he did like with Sony you're
just more like I don't know
I remember in high school I saw seven
pounds
and it was like a really sad [__]
movie but you're like yeah
but you know at the time like when I was
I was in high school when I went to go
see with all my friends and [__] and I
was like this is a bummer I know right
you thought it was like a [__]
things and you're just like what are you
trying to say welcome to Earth I don't
want to hear him saying Hell No or
something yeah
do you guys think an insane amount of
money
makes parenting easier or harder I think
just harder challenges different
challenges that not a lot of people know
how to handle I had an X was Rich As
[__] parents
never met more bored people in my life
and they were so involved in the girl
the girl's life that it was like
it was like obstructive like it was like
you are so bored and you go to the so
the worst thing is to the community
right they go to lunches with Rich
doctors and dentists and [__] like that
and then everyone has to compare their
kids to each other like as a almost like
sounds like an Asian family we all have
the same watches and Status symbols and
houses and square footage but how are
your kids doing and how are they doing
like on this the status true yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's everything oh my kid's
a doctor he's a surgeon he's at Harvard
or whatever if you don't have that then
then you can't brag this one right she
has to try to talk about your watch
collection but everybody already has
that it's weird right because it's all
checklisted now yeah yeah that makes
sense so I don't think what else is next
um if you've already can if you can
already get everything because I always
wonder that too about people that are
very powerful or very rich right they're
like okay well what's next you're like
80 years old you're probably about to
die what do you want and what kind of
moves are you trying to make in the
world you already have all this power
influence money
um I hope it's not Sinister but that's
what I wonder because everyone needs
purpose and like the next thing that
they do usually turn into some sort of
contribution yeah I hope so we'll give
them back hopefully yeah yeah yeah
end up having purpose and fulfill from
just that yeah like the Jeffrey Epstein
Foundation yeah great Foundation great
beautiful examples
[Music]
[Laughter]
we'll never know what happened you're
buying a [__] floor tile in the
Virgin Islands with your name on it
yes I got it can I see it no but it's
there oh thanks that's that's the funny
thing that's different too is that it
depends what you want for your kid right
like some people just want their kid to
continue whatever Legacy that they are
part of like yeah yeah we we're part of
this family that has this business
you're the next one to take it and they
don't give a [__] how you turn out as a
person but then if you're in the
Limelight like Will Smith is he's
expected to still be a good dad to the
public so he has to say this or else
people don't want to buy his [__] that's
why I don't really buy it because I'm
like you're supposed to be a good parent
yeah it's not that your kids are in
limelights that you still are okay to
push back what if like Will Smith had so
much money what does he care if you buy
his new thing what about that yeah what
about that Ryan because his career going
down whether it's money or not it's
still Pride I'm sure he doesn't want to
look like he doesn't want to be
remembered as the guy who [__] [__]
slaps somebody yeah you can't have that
be your book end like it's pretty
[__] rough man because if you have
money what else do you want is probably
reputation because you work so hard for
Bill building a brand and reputation how
do you like and in one moment dude it's
a little bit yeah it's like it's a
little unraveling because then people
are like taking back how they felt about
it you forgot he won Oscar yeah yeah
until I heard this I I almost forgot
that I don't want this guy's life so
like I used to think oh he probably has
a really sick life because he's such a
wholesome dude he didn't have to be
corrupt whatever and then you go wait
he's in an unhappy marriage his kids are
[__] batshit crazy they don't care
about him or it appears that way right
and I'm like
that I don't know there seems like
there's something off yeah that doesn't
seem like a good loving family to me
or maybe they're just going through it
no you're like turbulent I think you're
right no the internet says he's a cook
so he probably is yeah it doesn't seem
like a great place weird isn't it
they're like these articles have been
popping up they're like oh what happened
to this Hollywood star and I actually
like those because it's they're the ones
that like did a crazy one or two movies
and then they just went back to a small
town and and I think to the regular
person they're like oh they fell off or
whatever but I actually think that's the
smartest move is you just now go back to
your simple life but you're just set now
you never did that and you know I'm
guilty of this because I love him Rick
Moranis and earlier today we were
talking about how much we love Rick
Moranis off camera man yeah and but he
his wife died of like cancer and he had
to go home and raise his kids and he
chose to raise him in a small town and
this is like after all his success and
stuff like that and the Honey I Shrunk
the Kids franchise he tried it in a
small town he tried in a small town and
that's the thing and now he's a white
supremacist
in the face happy ending you gotta punch
the face in New York no but he um he
raised his kids he raises kids and like
you know in a the way he wanted to right
out of Hollywood out of all that [__]
yeah and like yeah he's irrespectful and
he's actually come out recently and said
he has no regrets he's so happy to go
for him yeah it's awesome is he gonna
star in honey I tried that in a small
town